It it almost feels surreal that I am telling you
this today, because I think many of us at least
would like to believe that this is not the type of
thing that would be possible in the United States.
But it is possible we would be naive to think it's
not possible. And that's why the FBI has started
vetting the National Guard troops who are
in Washington, D.C., to protect the city,
to protect the capital, to protect the White House
in advance of enduring Joe Biden's inauguration.
And the reason the FBI is vetting National Guard
troops is that there are fear of insider Trump
loyalists who may even assist in or participate in
an attack tomorrow, Inauguration Day. I'm almost
at a loss for words, but this should not come as
a total surprise because two weeks ago I told you
that Joe Biden's entire Secret Service team is
being replaced rather than the typical. Some Trump
Secret Service people carry over and some people
retire and then they bring in some new people,
which would be the standard thing because of
concerns about Trump loyalists in Secret Service.
Joe Biden is getting an all new team, including
some agents from the Obama era that worked with
Biden in his capacity as vice president, as well
as new agents not believed to be Trump loyalists.
So we knew that a couple of weeks ago. And now,
as you know, because of the Trump riots on January
6th, National Guard troops have been called to
Washington, D.C. and they've been patrolling the
streets and street corners of Washington, D.C.
for a week now. If you look at images of it,
it looks dystopian. It looks like things we
would imagine only happen in other countries, but
they're happening right here in the United States,
but it is not quite so simple. Defense officials
and the FBI are worried about an insider attack or
threat from these very service members involved in
securing Joe Biden's inauguration. And this has
led the FBI to start vetting all 25000 National
Guard troops coming to Washington, D.C., or
already in Washington, D.C. for this event.
Now, imagine what it takes to vet 25000 troops
to figure out might this be a Trump loyalist?
Has this person been visiting certain websites on
the Internet, coordinating with certain people on
the Internet? And unfortunately, that degree of
vetting is not going to be possible. What it is,
what it is going to include is some more
automated processes for looking through folks,
maybe more detailed looks at people from certain
areas or people with certain characteristics.
I don't even know how you vet twenty five
thousand people and they're expected to be
doing the vetting all the way up to tomorrow's
inauguration. And this is a situation where,
I mean, listen, the FBI will run everybody's names
through databases. They'll see if any of the names
appear on watch lists already maintained to see
if there's something alarming that comes up.
If there have been names of the troops that
have been associated with prior investigations
or terrorism related concerns. But the
deep vetting that would be done, like,
for example, for people who will be close
to Joe Biden in a Secret Service capacity,
you just can't do that with twenty five thousand
National Guard troops coming to Washington,
D.C. on relatively short notice. But the fact
that this is even being done is, of course,
horrifying and very, very scary. And I hate to
say this, I don't want to make this all negative.
Because we are removing Trump, that's a good
thing and hopefully getting a fresh start on
a lot of these issues that that we failed
on as a country over the last four years.
But this is an issue, radicalization
of law enforcement and military
that's been studied for a long time. The Brennan
Center for Justice has a report called Hidden in
Plain Sight Racism, White Supremacy and Far Right
Militancy and Law Enforcement. Now, we've known
for a long time that law enforcement tends to be
more conservative than the population at large.
Law enforcement tends to vote quite a bit
more for Republicans rather than Democrats.
The military is not historically made up of at
the sort of lower levels, particularly progressive
individuals, although in 2020, Joe Biden did
seem more support from within the military than
Democratic presidents have seen for a long time.
But this issue of militancy and white supremacy
and racism within law enforcement has been studied
for a long time by the Brennan Center for Justice.
And it is important to understand that it is a
widely known issue and that while, of course,
most I've said before, this is not an antique
cop show or an antimilitary show in terms of
the individuals, I continue to believe and
this is based on both everything I've read
empirically and my personal experience, most
police officers become police officers for the
right reasons. Most people who join the military
join the military not to go out and kill people in
cold blood or or they do join for what they see
as doing something good for their community or
their country. The unfortunate reality is that
law enforcement and the military also attract
disproportionately culturally conservative people,
disproportionately folks motivated more by fear
and and possibly anger, disproportionately more
people, too. And I hate to say it be sympathetic
to the ideas of far right militancy. Now,
that doesn't mean that it's the majority.
It's not. But relative to the population, they
are overrepresented. And so that's something
that has to be dealt with. Law enforcement
and the military have tried different ideas,
and so far it has not worked particularly well.
And it remains a, quote, persistent threat,
according to the FBI. So the point here is it
shouldn't be a surprise that this is a concern,
even including the National Guard troops that
will be supposedly securing Washington, D.C. for
the inauguration of Joe Biden. I'm hopeful, but
unsure if this late stage vetting that the FBI
is doing will be enough. But my hope is
that even if some individuals slip through
who are sympathetic to some of the goals of the
rioters and would be rioters, that they will be so
few and far between among the twenty five thousand
National Guard troops that it will not really lead
to an opportunity for anybody to do anything that
even resembles what we saw on January 6th. That's
my hope, and I hope it doesn't end up being a
naive hope. But we will be watching it as we will
be covering Joe Biden's inauguration tomorrow.
And I hope you will join me. We will be live
on YouTube, Twitch and Facebook starting at 11:00
a.m. Eastern Time, 8:00 a.m. Pacific Time. We will
start an hour before we will see the gathering in
Washington, D.C., the swearing in of Joe Biden as
president, the swearing in of Kamala Harris, vice
president. And then we will have a changing of the
guard. We will officially have it. Trump will be
out, Biden will be in, and we will go right into
demanding that Joe Biden do the things he promised
to do on day one. I'll give him until day two.
I'll be honest, all I think day, literally day one
is tough. But maybe the first full day, I expect
executive orders from Joe Biden on Thursday,
and we will be here with you for everything.
So we'll see you for that tomorrow.
We have a great show today. Let
me know if you'll be watching.
I'm on Twitter at David Pakman,